un peu d'humour à présent jérémy à 18
ans il a déjà en carrier entamé sa
carrière d'humoriste pour faire rire ce
jeune a redonné se met dans la peau d'un
macho rencontre avec ce drôle de garçon
qui veut amuser mais qui veut aussi vous
allez voir qu'on le prenne au sérieux
extrait de son admission
c'est au théâtre de charleville mézières
que jérémy répète le plus souvent avec
le soutien du directeur des lieux un
soutien précieux pour ce jeune homme qui
a déjà écrit un one man show extrêmement
difficile d'être crédible à 18 ans quand
vous arrivez à la porte d'un théâtre
goût dit ah j'ai créé un spectacle mais
vous avez quel âge 18 ans ah oui et vous
parlez de quoi parce que c'est ça les
gens se disent que forcément pour avoir
quelque chose de d'intéressant à dire il
faut avoir vécu jérémy a commencé à
écrire ses premiers sketches à 15 ans
depuis le mois de novembre il est
inscrit aux cours florent il aime faire
rire sur les relations hommes femmes
le voilà dans un extrait du gros machos
qui rentre à la maison d'ailleurs tu
vois plus je le vois ce chien que je me
dis vous ressemblez tous les deux et non
pas physiquement vous vie vos vies se
ressemblent énormément leurs gardes vous
n'avez tous les deux aucune notion de
l'heure qu'il est vous passez tous les
deux environ 8 à 9 heures par jour sur
le canapé vous vous levez uniquement
pour manger et faire vos besoins et le
quatrième point le plus déroutant vous
mettez tous les deux à gueuler le soir
quand je passe la porte et ça y est
elles chirol c'est reparti j'aime bien
apprendre des sujets qui choque les gens
en fait enfin j'aime bien tourner à la
dérision des sujets qui font pas rire
habituellement quoi et puis bon bain
dans un spectacle je pense que c'est
important donc j'ai mis quand même
quelques piliers dans les spectacles des
piliers pour moi c'est les gens fassent
et des sketches où les gens se
reconnaissent tout de suite quoi comme
la belle famille la dispute mais chose
comme çà ou là les gens se reconnaissent
qu un garçon quand il vous appelle et
qu'il est jeune ça donne à peu près ça
ouais ouais c'est moi moi je t'appelle
pas longtemps sinon ma mère elle va
gueuler mais c'est pour te dire
que je t'apprécie quoi vous voyez quoi
il a intimidé il a peur de vous un et
vous par contre de votre côté ça va très
déjà parce que le garçon qui vous
appelle vous le trouvez qu'on est moche
et puis aussi parce que bon je connais
vous vous sentez bien aussi parce que en
général vous avez entre entre 15 et 20
copine qui écoute sur l'ampli du
téléphone et puis qui gloussent assez
régulièrement c'est pierre palmade qui a
donné envie à jérémy de se lancer dans
le web même chose un artiste précoce qui
a connu le succès à 19 ans sans limite
et jérémy aimerait marcher sur ses
traces
[Musique]